hello there guys welcome to another
commentary video
so quite recently ewan mcgregor did an
interview and revealed some um
details about the obi-wan kenobi series
um the information i'm going to read out
to you guys is from the nerdist so
credit to this article will be in the
description below so make sure you go
check it out
anyway so this video is going to be
broken up into sections
so feel free to skip to whatever section
you want so will it be a limited series
so far it appears that the only one show
is a one and done standalone season
while speaking to entertainment tonight
mcgregor said
as i understand it's a standalone season
but he leaves open the possibility that
there could be more
when asked about a season two however i
don't think there will be a second
season because there was an interview
with kathleen kennedy
and she says and we're now developing
the limited
obi-wan kenobi series with deborah chow
so yeah she says he
limited obi-wan kenobi series which you
know makes me believe there'll
only be one season um which i think is
okay because it means the show won't
drag on it'll be nice and condensed
and who knows the episodes could be like
an hour long
so essentially if it's six episodes it
could be like a six hour long movie so
you know i think you'll be fine
when does filming begin mcgregor
confirmed in the same interview with
entertainment tonight
that the date for production started is
early 2021
he said spring next year we start i'm
really excited about it it's gonna be
great i think
reproduction start in 2021 i think we'll
see a 2022 release date
with late 2021 at the very least who's
behind the scenes
the untitled obi-wan kenobi series
director and executive producer
is deborah chao if you guys don't know
her she actually directed two episodes
of the mandalorian
episode three and seven which were
received very well by the fans
so i think she's a great choice for
adobe one series and you know guys with
all things star wars
kathleen kennedy is also an executive
producer
also ewan mcgregor is a producer on the
series
mcgregor i think he knows his character
quite well so
be interesting to see what he does for
the show who's in the cast
as of right now the only confirmed cast
member for this limited series
is ewen mcgregor as obi-wan kenobi of
course but that hasn't stopped rumors
from running
rampant about who else might be playing
a part in the series reports have been
coming fast and furious that hayden
christensen
is returning as anakin skywalker
and that there will be plenty of
flashbacks to the clone wars era fingers
crossed
that this is true i've been wanting to
see hayden return his anakin
since star was seven there was plenty of
rumors that he was going to show up in a
sequel trilogy as a force ghost
um at least we got him as a voice and
star was nine but to be honest i really
wanted to see him as a force ghost
so yeah there's room about him playing a
part in the one kenobi series i really
hope it's true which i do think it
is because you know obi-wan you know
struggled a lot with the past on
tatooine so i do think there'll be a lot
of flashbacks he'll have
you know almost like ptsd and he'll
probably have you know have flashbacks
to
anakin and his time of him probably a
lot of flashbacks to the mustafa scene
but you know we'll just have to wait and
see other rumors suggest that darth
vader will play a part
as would tremor morrison as clone
commander cody so with commander cody
i'm just thinking you know what
flashbacks we would have
possibly when he executed order 66 and
shot down
obi-wan could have a little flashback
there or maybe just
everyone's time with commander cody with
his clone legion
again i don't know but we'll just have
to wait and see
and also these are just rumors so none
of this is confirmed
so you know take these with a grain of
salt what is it about
plot detail surrounding the series is
quite limited the only thing we know for
certain is that it takes place
eight years after the events of revenge
of pacific and 11 years before a new
hope this puts obi-wan in the middle of
his 19-year exile on tatooine
current rumors suggests that the story
is focused on darth vader's quest to
find obi-wan
if that is the case it'll be interesting
to see how the producers great drama
from this scenario as we know
raider fails in this mission but as of
now all these reports about the story
are unconfirmed
how many episodes will there be right
now the episode counted six
episodes at least according to mcgregor
but it wouldn't be shocking if it is
increased or decreased um i did hear
rumors um quite a while ago that the
original episode count was
eight episodes but then it was decreased
to six
so um this lines up with what mcgregor
is saying here
i know many people might be disappointed
here and it's only six episodes
but you know it would be realistic guys
um if they go for like an hour each
that's
six hours of content obi-wan content and
to be honest
you know it's hard to make an ongoing
series about you know obi-wan's
exile and tatooine like you can only do
so much
you know i think they'll do a great job
i'm looking forward to the series
please also let me know in the comment
section below if you guys are excited
for this show
and what do you guys want to see in the
obi-wan show anyway i'll see you guys
in the next video